I was going rose my name's Peter Pat
there's a lot of simulation games out
there it's [ __ ] ridiculous and in
case you don't believe me I'm about to
prove it first game is a simulator of a
simulator I don't know what the [ __ ]
that means but I'm pretty interested um
oh there okay
I can't move though oh I can't okay why
is the trees doing that [ __ ] that is
that is scaring me they're gonna come
out and jump scare me or some [ __ ] you
know what [ __ ] simulator games I'm out
of here I'm gonna go out and have fun
well [ __ ] it doesn't look like I can I
guess I have no choice but to enjoy a
simulator of a simulator what the [ __ ]
am I doing with my life alright that was
fun
oh my god this is such a dumb idea next
up turtle simulator
I am excited for this one oh my god I
always wanted to be a turtle and now I
can really get the full experience
thanks to unity and Laci laziness can I
go back in the water you know what I
don't even want to spend all that time
going back it's not gonna be you know
what [ __ ] it I committed to this [ __ ]
thing I might as well try it's very it's
reminds me of some as me a falcon lover
I wonder if he's out here this must be
the plain white fields of Africa [ __ ] Oh
lover where are though oh okay then so
[ __ ] good so [ __ ] good oh my god
thank you whoever made that that was
very very enlightening
next up gorilla simulator all glitches
and bugs were supposed to happen okay
that's when you know you're gonna play a
good game all right so I'm a gorilla
I look pretty schwag II I've gotta say
hey might Oh a mite the [ __ ] when I come
will that come from I have the ability
that oh is it oh god what I'd sup mr.
gorilla your mission is to go to the
city and kill every human you see
this say alright you know barrels are
evil and they work with the guerrillas
it's all been proven I I fart by
right-clicking that is not Thai you know
it's a great game IGN would rate this
probably 11 out of 10 there's the humans
they can throw barrels to the [ __ ] is
his conspiracy 3 thinking what is why am
I still moving okay I'm fine what's he
doing there he was he was a human in
disguise oh they become gorillas when
they die life makes sense now it all
makes sense
alright yeah always Dave why the barrels
just walking randomly on the street oh
right then you know what my mom said oh
they become a gorilla as soon as he hit
them like we dodged don't you that dodge
[ __ ]
man videogame development has really
come far have you have you ever try to
throw a barrel at another person no well
I think we discovered something here I
think we discovered the truth all right
on a sec I realize sound like a human
dock nice boys yeah I don't have any
hair gel in my hair today I just want to
point that out in case you think I look
extra fat or something I can spawn
humans okay all right then spawn a
gorilla it cheating me oh god what
happened what is going on life is life I
think shrek had something to do with
this all right
that is about as fun as we will have
with that mixed-up rock simulator oh boy
am I excited for this one thank you
unity for making all these amazing games
possible Rock simulator select a time
day night or dubstep warning may cause
seizures will save dubstep relies let's
start with the day all right
this reminds me of turtle simulator all
right time I rock this is a dream come
true for me I always wanted to be a rock
and it's pretty underwhelming
this is it it's this [ __ ] it
no one's gonna pick me up and throw me
or anything I'm just gonna be here all
day if I wanted to be a rock and you
could just go outside and become a ball
and just sit down all right I don't need
I don't need you patronizing me all
right let's try night mode see if that's
any more interesting and the short
answer to that is [ __ ] no let's try
the dubstep mode it should be pretty
[ __ ] amazing
that'd okay I am so stoned right now all
right
I've seen it all that's okay next up
traffic simulator I'm just supposed to
stay in traffic who would play this why
am I playing this next up diving
simulator this looks amazing
mash spacebar oh my god how do I control
him oh alright that's how you dive I
think procedure key I'm supposed to
click those e.x hamburgers [ __ ] oh I
love how they score me even though I got
brutally murder yeah oh those pink
shorts are so good
ah [ __ ]
oh come on what [ __ ] off
duck simulator we have to check this one
out all right we're duck and we can go
into water stay underwater and go up the
water and down to water and out oh okay
all right
so this you made a pain animation with
two frames and it's a game that is this
is the most effort I have ever seen into
anything I'm like I think this is the
first time I can honestly say that I put
more effort into the [ __ ] video this
[ __ ] game what the [ __ ] [ __ ] I
love it so much this is the best game i
have ever [ __ ] played alright tree
simulator 2013 it's a bit outdated but
that doesn't mean it's not good oh my
god this is almost as good as a rock
simulator please don't tell me this is 8
please let everyone gimmick beyond me
just being a [ __ ] tree this game has
four point [ __ ] two rating this is
some next-level [ __ ] gameplay man
holy [ __ ] why did he get such high
[ __ ] rating 4.2 4.2 my god
next up setting simulator oh my god is
I'm getting pissed off this is like a
rage game without any gameplay I'm
seriously like what the [ __ ] alright
that was fun
it's a pre-alpha what are you expecting
to do in the future
what do you want to do with that how is
the full version gonna be get a [ __ ]
[ __ ] alright last but not least goat
petting simulator
alright this is all right that's my arm
it looks like I'm gonna face his anus
let's be honest here that this is really
what I want to do alright where is the
[ __ ] goat where I can hear you you
[ __ ] oh you're so tiny Jesus Christ
alright so is this to fill in some weird
[ __ ] perverts dream with goats or
some [ __ ]
there we go alright alright I think this
is the probably the best one out of all
of them I probably rated like 5 million
goats out of three this is optional ass
fisting goat simulator you know you
thought goat simulator was good but can
you pet goats in that game no this is
clearly a superior title man I can fist
his face if I feel like it oh my god
best game ever and I can do this
alright I am done with life now thank
you and thanks to all the amazing
developers out there you true your work
truly truly make our life better so go
ahead and leave a like if you enjoy
watching buzz at the sky cover today and
I'll see you next one stay awesome bros
Rafi hushed